[Musique]
qui a introduit les premiers cochon en
amérique
nul autre que christophe colomb lors de
son deuxième voyage vers le nouveau
monde en 493 lutte cochons font la
traversée avec lui jusqu'à l'île
d'hispaniola avant l'arrivée des
premiers explorateurs l'amérique
n'abriter aucun port ces animaux
domestiques et près de dix mille ans
avant jésus-christ sont issus de
populations de sangliers d'europe et
d'asie mais c'est un autre conquistadors
hernando de soto qui introduit promis qu
au chaud en amérique du nord continental
aucun 139
il débarque 13 cochon en floride trois
ans plus tard on en dénombrait 7 semble
sans compter ceux qui avaient déserté
l'expédition et qui deviendront les
premiers cochons sauvages d'amérique au
fil de la colonisation du territoire
d'autres ports s'échapperont et
retourneront à l'état sauvage au début
des années 1900 essangui est porté de
robe pour la chasse sont aussi être
d'hui à différents endroits aux états
unis certains animaux en fuite se
reproduiront avec des porcs domestique
ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui de nombreuses
populations hybride existe à l'état
sauvage
aux états unis seulement on compterait
aujourd'hui plus de 6 millions de
cochons sauvages